- Mention that you got
engaged already last year.
So how is the wedding planning going?
Is it fun or-
- It's-
- Do you wanna run?
- Do I wanna run?
No, um-
- I started planning a
wedding whenever I got,
and it was so overwhelming and it became
about other people that I stopped
and I was like, this is too much.
My life is already giving to everybody.
Like, this should be for me.
- By the way,
when you said that
she looked at me and she went like that.
'Cause she was like-
- It does, it becomes for other people.
And it's like, wait, wait,
wait. This should be for us.
But I hope, enjoy it though.
Big weddings are fun.
- No, it's exciting.
We're just trying to find the right venue,
but we already have the
entertainment booked.
And I've said this a thousand times-
- I love your entertainment.
How did you get Michael Buble performing?
- That's right.
- Michael Buble is performing.
(audience cheers)
That's amazing.
- He is gonna be, he's gonna
be performing "Baby Shark"
at our wedding.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
No, we've just become really
close friends past five years
and this past year even closer.
And he's just, you know
him, he's just the best guy.
- First of all, people don't know,
like if you don't see a show,
if you go to a show, you do.
But he is one of the funniest people ever.
- He's a standup comic. It's amazing.
- He's a standup comic that
just sings extremely well.
- He also sings.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's just a side note.
- So it's funny.
So I actually said, I did
this project with him.
I directed a few videos for him
and we just worked together.
And you know, he's like,
"What do I owe you?"
And I was like, "Nothing,
nothing, nothing."
He goes, "Well, please let
me do something for you."
And I was like, "Sing at our wedding."
And he was like, "Done."
And we're like, we shook on it. Done.
And I was like, oh, he
probably just said that.
And then later we saw him and he goes,
"All right, so when are
we all getting married?
Like, when does it happen?"
I was like, "So you are?"
He's like, "Of course, I said I was."
I was like, "Okay, great."
- A lot of people say things
and don't follow through.
- I know!
- That's incredible.
- It's a major bromance.
I love him.
- Oh my God.
- I might marry him.
I might marry him.
(audience laughs)
- Are you willing to accept-
- See ya later.